he's coming at ya Florida Gators aren't
afraid of much they're certainly not
afraid of me but we're here to protect
them from something they should be
scared of it definitely isn't happy to
see us a sneaky little lizard form
Argentina I'm Wes Larson a wildlife
biologist and lover of the outdoors for
as long as I can remember I'm traveling
the country to find the next generation
of conservationists the people on the
front lines of the fight to understand
our planet and protect the animals we
share it with
my first stop takes me all the way down
at the southern wilds of Florida also
known as the Everglades they're huge hot
and home to one of the fiercest
predators on the planet the American
alligator these researchers from the
University of Florida have taken me deep
into the swamp to survey the local Gator
population oh wow I just gotta say like
ever since I was a kid it fantasized
about coming to Florida and meeting
alligators up close
alligators are at the top of the food
chain crucial to maintaining the
ecological balance of the Everglades but
despite this dominance alligators are
under threat from a foreign invader that
no one saw coming
the Argentine black and white tegu
facing that threat head-on are UF
researchers Jenna Cole and Sarah cook
[Music]
how's it going so we are out here
looking for invasive reptiles so we're
gonna be looking for the Argentine black
and white tegu they're just a huge
problem preying on our native species
tegu populations have exploded in recent
years so Jenna and Sarah are
painstakingly trapping and removing them
one by one so how many traps are we
gonna be checking so we've got 160 traps
out here a long way yeah so I mean it's
a pretty excessive trap way 160 traps
spread over miles of uninhabited
marshland where do you even begin well
start at trap number one sort of first
trap of the day yeah this will be the
first one and it looks like you've got
something oh cool that's so crazy
yeah he's biting in the trap kind of a
scary little predator like a little
dinosaur
yeah they essentially they are little
dinosaurs uh-huh and all you had in this
trap to bait him in was a chicken yep
just a single chicken egg so if you
could imagine a whole nest of alligator
eggs
[Music]
I mean it just looks like a little egg
eater but it's not only alligators that
are at risk
Peggy's will eat just about anything the
ground nesting birds
the turtles snakes all those animals are
potential prey for these large lizards a
single tegu can consume an entire nest
of eggs in one sitting so we don't take
any chances it's straight into the bag
for removal son I'm bagging my first say
goo here there we go got it up and up
and down like up and down yeah there we
go
well one down let's catch 160 more right
we have to be very conscious of where
we're holding the bag because they can
actually bite you through the best
you've been bit okay you also have to
watch if you set the bag down they can
run away in the back yes you have to sit
down the ground will step inside what
we're doing what oh yeah the bag just
hops up yes that's crazy
[Music]
the farther we go the more apparent it
is just how many tattoos are crawling
around out here another one down we got
another one
awesome grumpy ones yeah I can't believe
how many there are out of here it's fun
there is a whole breeding population of
them saving the Everglades one tegu at a
time this is the end of the line for
these tegus each one that Jenna and her
team captures is brought back to the lab
and euthanized and that's tough for a
reptile lover like Jenna you really have
to look at a big picture I liked a goose
and it's unfortunate that there is no
alternative but it's not just that we're
removing them and that's it we are using
them to learn more about the species so
that we can mitigate and prevent them
from causing more terrible damage than
what's what's going on already
yeah that's not a small one huh no he's
not a small one a couple hundred yards
from where we just caught a tegu in this
little canal there's a pretty big
alligator just kind of hanging out so it
shows that they really are occupying the
same space it's not impossible to
imagine a nest around here coming up oh
yeah
we caught a number of tables today out
here they're from Argentina originally
so how did they get to Florida the
general consensus on how the techies got
here is through the pet trade they were
either released or escaped into the
ecosystem they're very small and very
cute when they are first sold and first
hatched and as they grow people tend to
realize that they may be in for a lot
more than they bargained for and then in
the middle of the swamp we come across
one very special table so we've got a
goo here that has a transmitter on it so
I believe that means that we actually
get to pull them out after we bagged in
and I actually get to get my hands on
him that's right right yep in this vast
wilderness the research team has
transmitters on only six taboos so it's
a real stroke of luck that we found this
one when they square him you don't grab
a tail yeah and that's just cuz it can
attach yeah drop it I can definitely
tell there's some real strength we've
obviously got a tegu out of the trap
that we're handling so why is it that
we're able to pull this one out we are
actually following him around and
learning more about where he lives and
what he's doing out here so that we can
learn more ways to effectively trap and
remove them from this Everglades so stop
he's like a little spy for you guys yeah
okay so he's like a double agent it's
hard to believe that something as small
as releasing some pet lizards can
threaten the health of an entire
ecosystem my time here has proven to me
just how delicate that balance can be
the scientists we met from UF are
fighting a daily battle to write some of
our wrongs it's hot humid and
frustrating work but these biologists
care deeply about native species and
tagging along help me understand just
how important their battle
[Music]